ces derniers jours
les observateurs internationaux avaient
dit ne pas avoir pu constater la
présence de la présence de possibles
explosifs notamment sur les toits des
réacteurs 3 et 4 ça c'est une
affirmation des services de
renseignement
Ukrainiens mais ils n'ont pas non plus
eu accès à ses toits donc ça c'est la
c'est la requête qui a été faite par les
observateurs externes de son côté Kiev
averti qu'effectivement Moscou prépare
une attaque alors ne prévoit pas
forcément de faire exploser les
réacteurs nucléaires ce n'est pas ça
dont nous parlons mais c'est de mettre
en scène une attaque pour pouvoir
ensuite accuser Kiev d'avoir bombardé sa
propre centrale alors ces accusations du
côté de Moscou envers l'Ukraine et bien
elle pose question puisque cette
centrale nucléaire elle a été occupée
depuis plusieurs mois depuis l'an
dernier par les Russes donc seuls les
Russes y ont accès seul Moscou serait
capable de planter par exemple des
explos ifs sur ces toits donc c'est une
situation extrêmement dangereuse c'est
une situation
à laquelle Kiev avertit le monde entier
sur les dégâts considérables qu'une
telle explosion pourrait évidemment
causer non seulement à l'Ukraine mais
aussi qui s'étendrait à l'ensemble de
l'Europe